c'est encore le début d'une merveilleuse
semaine de travail sur le chantier
bonjour tête ça c'est pas de chance ont
tous les jours c'est la même chose
attention tu rebondis boîtes noires elle
m'a coupé la route
arrête de faire une fixette sur la
vitesse profite de la vie tu appelles ça
une vie plutôt tu accepteras l'ennui et
la profonde ne tenu de l'existence non
plus tu connaîtras d'honneur
je voudrais aller
oh non
mais qu'est ce qui m'arrive
tu es devenu un monstre on va te faire
soigner et je suis très bien tu
t'appelles ça allait très bien
dépaysé le petit guerrier la sauvegarde
frais
je m'appelle turbo coup si je pouvais
changer de nom moi c'est oui flash et ça
c'est mon écurie
je suis rapide communaux prônait une
home c'est pas rapide en soit je te vois
toujours avec la rapidité et nos talents
on va faire un malheur qui grille la
grenouille
un tour du monde et
c'est un escargot bonjour l'accueil tous
ces escargots croit en moi c'est pour
eux que je fais un escargot ne peut pas
disputer une course réservée aux
automobiles
décidément tu es mon rayon de soleil
voiture plan alors arrête de conduire
dans une voiture waouh
vous avez vu tard imagine que tu te
réveilles demain matin que tu es perdu
tes pouvoirs c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que j'en profite aujourd'hui
umaga sur hbo
il va si vite que le reste du monde a
l'air de tourner au ralenti b